Ce qui sera voté aujourd'hui, ce
qui sera présenté aux
parlementaires va changer nos
vies pour le mieux espère le
gouvernement. On verra la
réaction des gens. Bon après-
midi. Ici Patrice trois au
centre de l'information à
Montréal. C'est le quatrième
budget de Bill Morneau. Dernier
budget des libéraux avant la
campagne électorale cet automne.
Le ministre des Finances veut
faire un coup de circuit pour
faire oublier l'autre histoire
qui roule beaucoup à Ottawa,
SNC-Lavalin. Avec moi, René
Vézina, Michel C. Auger et
Daniel Thibeault.
Je commence avec vous Daniel.
Bien sûr que l'on attend le
budget qui sera déposé en
principe à 16 heures. Mais il y
a une joute politique qui se
joue à Ottawa. Les conservateurs
sont furieux. Ils veulent que
l'on parle de la crise SNC-
Lavalin. Le comité de la
justice, les libéraux ont dit
que c'est terminé. On va
retarder, on va tout faire pour
retarder le dépôt du budget.
- C'est une tactique que les
conservateurs ont commencée à
préparer hier. Hier soir, on a
retardé un vote qui devait avoir
lieu hier soir. On l'a repoussé
à aujourd'hui. Ce qui fait que
ce vote sur une motion banale
concernant les travaux d'un
comité sur les baleines aura
lieu à 15 heures 55. Par la
suite, ce sera le vote qui va
durer une dizaine de minutes. On
dit : ne vous attendez pas à un
budget avant 16 heures 45. M.
Trudeau a commenté la tactique
qu'ils déplorent évidemment.
Comme vous dîtes, il y a
beaucoup de trucs dans le livre
pour faire reporter ou en tout
cas faire patienter les
parlementaires. Ça pourrait être
plus long que 45 minutes. Tout
cela parce que les conservateurs
veulent que l'on parle de
l'affaire SNC-Lavalin.
- Les gens à qui j'ai parlé
aujourd'hui chez les
conservateurs ont dit : on ne
vous dira pas tout. Mais on a
dit qu'on allait utiliser les
outils pour s'assurer de
maintenir l'affaire SNC-Lavalin.
L'une des personnes à qui j'ai
parlé plus tôt m'a dit que l'on
avait déjà étudié un certain
nombre de scénarios. Vous savez
que ça peut se revigorer contre
l'utilisateur de la tactique.
Tout cela parce qu'on est fâché
que ce matin le comité de la
justice des libéraux qui sont
majoritaires sur le comité ont
décidé de mettre un terme aux
travaux.
Ce n'est pas la vie des
conservateurs ni des
néo démocrate.
À la sortie du comité de la
justice, M. Sheer a eu des mots
très durs.
ANDREW SCHEER, chef
Parti conservateur du Canada
- Je vais être clair :
il s'agit d'un abus de pouvoir.
C'est un affront à la démocratie
et une attaque contre
le Parlement. Les Canadiens
s'attendent à plus de
transparence.
Et en mettant fin à l'enquête
du Comité de la justice sur son
propre scandale de corruption,
Justin Trudeau se moque
de chacun d'entre eux.
- Daniel, on a un extrait de la
période de question qui a eu
lieu aujourd'hui pendant que les
journalistes sont en huis clos.
Les deux oppositions
on des tirs groupés contre M.
Trudeau.
ANDREW SCHEER, chef,
Parti conservateur du Canada
- Le premier ministre a nommé un
ancien ministre libéral de
l'époque du scandale des
commandites pour examiner son
scandale de corruption.
Puis les libéraux siègent au
comité de la justice, ont mis
fin aux travaux du comité
sur cette affaire.
Qu'est-ce que le premier
ministre tente de cacher?
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Le comité étudie le dossier
depuis cinq semaines.
Les Canadiens, ont pu entendre
toutes les perspectives.
Le commissaire aux conflits
d'intérêts continue d'étudier le
dossier. On dit depuis le début
que l'accord de réparation était
et demeure la décision du
procureur général
- La personne à qui M. Scheer
faisait référence en parlant
d'un libéral c'était admettre
... c'était Anne McLellan.
On devrait étudier si
la fonction de ministre de la
justice et de procureur général
doit être séparé.
- Parlons quand même du budget.
Il y a un retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire. Est-ce qu'il y a un
plan sur trois ou quatre ans?
- Pour un calendrier de retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire, ne
retenait pas votre souffle. Il y
aura une tendance. On va voir ùu
cela va s'en aller. On mise sur
des revenus plus élevés que
prévu. Les dépenses du
gouvernement qui se sont
stabilisés. Le ratio dette -
PIB.
Et les mesures qui ont été
présentées qui vont cibler entre
autres les milléniaux.
Pour aider les gens à se
recycler, l'incitatif pour
l'achat de véhicules électriques
entre autres. Et la compensation
des producteurs laitiers
canadiens qui ont essuyé un
certain nombre de compromis
après l'accord de libre-échange
avec les États-Unis et le
Mexique entre autres.
Un premier pas dans cette
direction.
- On va suivre les méandres du
code de conduite des libéraux.
Michel, une petite analyse de ce
que l'on va vivre dans les
prochaines heures. Ce sont des
tactiques parlementaires pour
faire parler de soi.
L'opposition ne va pas s'en
priver.
- C'est le grand moment du
gouvernement et on veut le
gâcher.
C'est arrivé dans les années 90,
j'étais à Ottawa déjà, je me
souviens de Marc Lalonde qui
avait lu un budget au théâtre de
la presse plutôt qu'au Parlement
en soirée. Les conservateurs
avaient fait des tactiques
dilatoires. J'espère que l'on ne
se rendra pas là. Les règlements
de la chambre ont changé depuis
ce temps-là.
- René Vézina, on a beaucoup
parlé de l'assurance
médicaments. Premiers pas d'un
programme national canadien. Au
Québec, on a une assurance
médicaments partielle pour les
gens qui ne sont pas assurés au
privé. Également aide à l'accès
à la propriété et formation de
la main-d'oeuvre.
- C'est la dernière année du
mandat de l'actuel gouvernement.
C'est habituellement un budget
dans ce contexte qui est un peu
truffé de certaines friandises.
Il risque de ne pas y en avoir
beaucoup parce que la marge de
manoeuvre du gouvernement est
très limitée.
On ne pourra pas... il faut bien
comprendre une chose, même si on
s'en va vers le retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire, de
l'avis des analystes, l'année
2019 ne sera pas la plus
vigoureuse en termes de
croissance économique. On va
surveiller les trois T :
le travail.
La requalification des
travailleurs. Jouer sur
l'expérience. Mettre en valeur
les travailleurs expérimentés.
C'est vrai qu'il y a plein de
gens qui pourraient être mis à
contribution.
Dire expérimenter et plus jolies
que dire âgé.
Il y a la question de transport
également. Des subventions
accrues pour l'électrification.
Transport en matière
d'infrastructures. Il y a des
demandes pour le transport en
commun.
Et tant qu'à parler de
transport, il y a le transport
de données. Il y a cette
question de l'accès à Internet.
Ça fait des décennies que l'on
en parle. Même dans la
périphérie des grandes villes,
il y a encore des déserts.
Finalement, la transition. Pour
Internet, on évoque 2030 pour
l'Internet. Il peut y avoir
d'autres révolutions
technologiques.
À la veille des élections, on
aime bien cibler les groupes. On
verra dans les détails. Il
faudra fouiller.
- On veut viser les 25 ans et
moins pour l'accès à la
propriété. Ça sonne des cloches
dans l'Ouest ou le prix des
maisons est telle que les jeunes
ne peuvent pas acheter. Le
déficit, ça reste un débat. Les
conservateurs ont décidé que
c'était leur cheval de bataille.
Michel.
- Le gouvernement, souvenez-
vous, a pris les commandes avec
un déficit zéro. Quand M.
Trudeau est arrivé, il a dit
nous allons avoir un plan pour
la dernière année de notre
mandat de retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire. Les conservateurs
vont utiliser cela en disant et
ils n'auront pas tort que l'on
répare le toit de la maison
quand il fait beau hé non quand
ils. Après 10 ans de croissance,
on peut s'attendre à un
ralentissement économique.
Personne ne va parler de
récession mais ce n'est pas
impossible. Évidemment, s'il y
avait un ralentissement
économique, ou une récession, le
déficit augmenterait.
- M. Trudeau va tabler sur le
livre qu'il a en main. Il a fait
son entrée. Il a besoin que son
ministre des Finances tape un
coup de circuit aujourd'hui. Un
coup sûr, ce ne sera pas
suffisant. Ce budget doit
changer la conversation à Ottawa
et doit prendre le dessus sur
l'histoire SNC-Lavalin.
- On veut que ce budget devienne
le point tournant et que ce soit
l'élément dont on parle. Jusqu'à
la prochaine campagne
électorale. Les conservateurs et
les néo démocrate souhaite le
contraire. À quel point le petit
livre va vraiment permettre au
gouvernement de recentrer le
message, de rediriger les choses
ailleurs? Les travaux du comité
de la justice sont terminés. On
peut peut-être mettre de l'avant
ses idées. On ne connaît pas le
contenu du budget. Demain la
semaine prochaine, il y aura des
députés sur la route pour en
faire la promotion. On veut que
cela change le ton, on veut
renverser la vapeur.
- On va faire une tournée avec
nos collègues journalistes.
Alexandra Duval à Saint-
Georges, Catherine Gauthier
à Montréal et Valérie Gamache
à Vancouver.
On verra si les voeux seront
exaucés.
- Les producteurs laitiers
attendent le budget de pied
ferme. Ils auront droit à des
compensations, mais de quel
ordre? Ils ont perdu beaucoup
d'argent depuis la signature du
traité transpacifique et de
d'autres traités. On s'est rendu
sur une ferme. Le producteur
laitier raconte qu'il perd 120
$ bruts par jour. Alors faites
le calcul sur une année. C'est
beaucoup. Il a même dû réduire
ses effectifs. Il sera à
l'écoute du budget. Ça passe ou
ça casse avec le gouvernement
Trudeau.
YVES LABBÉ, producteur laitier
- Il nous a promis une
compensation pleine et entière,
il a promis de protéger la
gestion de l'offre puis à chaque
promesse, il ne les a jamais
tenues. Donc, on va essayer
d'autre chose. On se tourne vers
une alternative. On va voir
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans
l'opposition si ça peut être
mieux. Et puis c'est sûr et
certain que le climat...
s'il veut rétablir le climat
de confiance, son budget
aujourd'hui est très important.
Sinon, on n'investira pas
dans le domaine laitier.
- Sinon attention à la campagne
électorale. Ce ne sera pas jojo.
On croit qu'il y aura une
annonce dans le budget pour
apaiser un peu ces gens qui
attendent. Un autre dossier
important, c'est le financement
du transport en commun. À
Québec, ça sonne une cloche.
- Ça rime avec tramway. Le
financement du tramway est
attendu avec les deux budgets,
fédéral et provincial.
Il y a 800 millions qui fêtent
l'objet d'une chicane entre
Québec et Ottawa. Le maire est
carrément exaspéré. Il ne s'est
pas gêné pour passer son
message.
RÉGIS LABEAUME, maire de Québec
- Il y a jamais eu autant
d'argent sur la table pour
le transport collectif,
il y en a à Québec, il y en a
à Ottawa. Mais là on se chicane,
hein, pour savoir si mon père
est plus fort que le tien,
parce que c'est sûr qu'une
chicane provinciale...
fédérale-provinciale, ça peut
être payant politiquement,
mais c'est pas payant
politiquement pour la Ville
de Québec, puis on en a marre.
- Les deux budgets sont très
attendus pour la ville de Québec
pour ce vaste projet de plus de
3 milliards de dollars.
- Merci Alexandra.
Catherine Gauthier, à Montréal,
il y a aussi beaucoup d'attentes
en matière de transport
en commun?
- Québec veut son tramway mais
Montréal et surtout
Valérie Plante veut la ligne
rose. On souhaite que le fédéral
investisse davantage dans le
transport en commun. Les grandes
villes du pays, comme Montréal,
Vancouver et Toronto, elle
demande un financement permanent
pour les projets de transport en
commun. On voudrait avoir le
financement à hauteur de nos
ambitions. Vancouver veut
prolonger son sky train.
Il y a beaucoup de projets y
compris à Montréal.
FRANÇOIS PÉPIN, président,
Trajectoire Québec
- Pour Montréal, il y a
énormément de besoins, parce que
là il y a le REM qui va se faire
mais quand on pense entre autres
au niveau de compléter le réseau
de métro, il y a la ligne bleue
évidemment qui n'a pas encore
été vraiment confirmée, là
c'est sûr il peut y avoir des
extensions de la ligne jaune
sur la Rive-Sud, la ligne orange
au moins jusqu'à Bois-Francs
sinon à Laval, et puis
il y a éventuellement peut-être
un projet de ligne rose.
- Catherine, il y aura dans ce
budget de l'argent
supplémentaire pour les
acheteurs de voitures
électriques.
- Possiblement pas pour les
voitures hybrides. C'est une
grande différence. C'est bien
parce que ça va faire qu'on va
peut-être diminuer les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre. Mais ça
ne va pas diminuer le trafic.
Ce n'est pas dans les cartons
d'accorder un crédit d'impôt
pour le titre mensuel de
transport en commun.
- L'accès à la propriété pour
les jeunes familles, les 25 ans
et moins. Chez vous, ça coûte
tellement cher. On attend des
choses concrètes dans ce budget.
- Une maison se vend
1,4 millions de dollars en
moyenne. Un ménage de 150 000 $
n'a pas les moyens de s'acheter
une maison à Vancouver. On a
rencontré une famille qui a
acheté un duplex il y a cinq
ans. On a tout mis en place pour
tenter de rentabiliser cet
investissement. On a une
garderie, on profite du tourisme
en louant une chambre. On tente
de faire en sorte d'optimiser
les investissements. Ce sont des
familles qui voient toute
fracture ébranler le budget.
C'est le cas lorsqu'il y a une
facture de médicaments. Le coût
élevé de la vie à Vancouver fait
en sorte que ça rend le
recrutement de main-d'oeuvre
difficile. On a l'impression
d'avoir de la difficulté à avoir
les services comme en éducation
ou en santé.
JAMES RANKIN,
résident de Vancouver
- On se cherche des... aussi des
services de garde, on cherche
des enseignants pour les écoles,
on cherche des services qui
aident les familles ici autour
de la communauté. Si ces
personnes-là n'ont pas accès au
logement, ça veut dire qu'il
y aura moins de spécialistes,
moins de professionnels
sur qui on peut compter.
Donc ça rend la difficile pour
nous, mais affecte aussi tout
le monde de la communauté autour
de nous.
- Depuis plusieurs années, lors
de chaque dépôt de budget, on
parle d'un dossier fort
important pour des millions de
Canadiens. L'accès Internet
haute vitesse.
- Il y a plusieurs Canadiens qui
n'ont pas accès à Internet haute
vitesse. Dans les milieux
ruraux, un Canadien sur cinq à
une mauvaise connexion Internet.
On veut régler cela. Cela a des
conséquences économiques et
sociales.
Les communautés ne sont pas
servies.
- Ça donne une idée des attentes
aujourd'hui. Merci.
Je vous rappelle mesdames et
messieurs qu'en principe, ce
sera le dépôt du budget à 16
heures. Mais les conservateurs
ont utilisé toutes sortes de
procédés parlementaires pour
retarder le dépôt du budget.
Mais il pourrait quand même y
avoir à 16 heures une permission
de donner les informations.
Daniel, vous êtes là.
- À l'heure actuelle, il n'y a
pas d'indication à l'effet que
les conservateurs ont décidé de
changer d'idée. Le calendrier
que l'on nous expose est
toujours le fameux vote sur
cette motion sénatoriale qui
aura lieu. On est en seconde
lecture. On est dans la période
prévue. Les conservateurs
n'auraient pas l'intention de
changer d'idée.
- On écoute M. Morneau en
direct.
(en anglais)
(applaudissements)
- copie du discours du budget
qui ont été distribué. Ce n'est
pas clair pour moi si à quatre
heures on pourra donner avec nos
collègues les détails.
Le ministre tente de répliquer
aux manoeuvres des conservateur.
- Ce que l'on croit comprendre,
c'est que M. Morneau a déposé
les documents.
Il allait lever le huis clos à
la fermeture des marchés à 16
heures. On pourrait être en
mesure de parler du contenu du
budget avant le discours.
Les marchés seront fermés.
- C'est une bonne nouvelle.
- C'est une façon de
contrecarrer la tactique
conservatrice. Voyons voir
comment ça va se dérouler dans
les prochaines secondes.
- On va faire une courte pause.
Nous allons revenir avec les
détails du budget de Bill
Je m'attends à retrouver des
montants dans le budget de cet
après-midi concernant la ligne
bleue, 1,4 milliard.
- Il y a jamais eu autant
d'argent sur la table mais on se
chicane pour savoir si mon père
est plus fort que le tien.
- Le fédéral a fait des belles
annonces mais à chaque fois le
chèque n'est pas dans la malle.
- On s'attend aussi avoir des
compensations pour les
producteurs laitiers.
- Justin Trudeau pense que le
budget va satisfaire les
Canadiens. Les conservateurs
ne vont pas rester les bras
croisés.
- Mesdames et Messieurs bonjour,
bonne fin d'après-midi. Vous
voyez des images du premier
ministre Justin Trudeau et de
son ministre des finances Bill
Morneau il y a quelques secondes
à Ottawa avec le budget entre
les mains. Monsieur Trudeau qui
souhaite de tout coeur que ce
budget puisse changer le climat
à Ottawa, au Parlement. Vous
savez que depuis quatre semaines
on parle de SNC-Lavalin. Il y a
des choses dans ces budgets qui
vont vous toucher directement :
achat des autos électriques,
assurance médicaments, accès à
la propriété. Budget, c'est un
texte important en démocratie.
Le gouvernement s'exprimait
changer les règles du jeu. Avec
moi, Gérald Fillion, Madeleine
Blais-Morin, Michel C. Auger,
René Vézina, bonjour à vous...
vous sortez tout juste de ce
huis clos qui sera levé ou qui
est déjà levé, il y a quelques
secondes. C'est un budget
politiquement important.
Économiquement on verra s'il y a
beaucoup de choses dedans.
- C'est politiquement important
parce que c'est le tout dernier
budget avant les élections
d'octobre prochain. On peut se
poser la question : est-ce que
c'est oui ou non un budget
électoraliste? Je vais y aller
en demi-teinte, en partie, c'est
électoraliste parce qu'il y a
quand même dans ce budget des
mesures de 5 milliards de
dollars pour l'année qui
s'entame. On veut entre autres
faciliter la vie des aînés dans
le besoin, on veut aussi
faciliter l'achat d'une première
propriété et on veut jeter les
bases d'un programme d'assurance
médicaments. Donc vous voyez, on
est clairement dans les plates-
bandes du parti néodémocrate,
beaucoup moins dans celle du
parti conservateur, parce que la
toute première ligne que le
parti conservateur va vérifier,
c'est celle du déficit. Il y a
effectivement encore cette année
un déficit et pas de plan de
retour à l'équilibre budgétaire.
Un déficit cette année qui frôle
les 20 milliards de dollars, ce
qui était prévu ou à peu près
lors de la dernière mise à jour
économique de l'automne dernier.
C'est aussi électoraliste en
partie parce qu'il y a certaines
mesures qui ne sont pas
clairement définies, donc ça va
permettre au gouvernement de
faire toutes sortes d'annonce
d'ici octobre prochain pour
détailler les programmes qui ont
été annoncés. Mais quand on
parle d'électoraliste, on dit
aussi parfois que ces
clientélistes. Je dirais que ce
n'est pas tout a fait le cas, on
en est pas à saupoudrer des
millions à gauche et à droite
pour des petites clientèles, on
est quand même dans des grands
programmes.
- Gérald le bonjour à vous.
Bonne fin d'après-midi. On a vu
un premier tableau, on peut
peut-être le revoir, ce sont les
paramètres dépensent, revenus,
comme un budget comme chez nous,
revenus, dépenses, réserves,
égal presque 20 milliards de
déficits.
- Revenus de 339 milliards de
dollars. Dépenses de 355
milliards. Et la réserve parce
qu'on continue de maintenir une
réserve budgétaire de 3
milliards. Donc le déficit est
un peu plus important
qu'attendu. On assume le déficit
budgétaire. On maintient cela.
Et dans ce qui est énoncé, il y
a quatre grandes mesures je vous
dirai quand on regarde les faits
saillants, on vient bonifier
l'aide à l'achat d'une première
propriété, c'est ce qu'on avait
mentionné dans les derniers
jours. Ça avait été ébruité.
Bonification de l'aide à l'achat
d'une première propriété. Je
vais vous l'expliquer. Crédit à
la formation pour les personnes
âgées de 25 à 64 ans qui sont
des travailleurs. Vous pourrez
amasser de l'argent avec 250 $
par année, et si vous en avez
besoin pour une formation, vous
y aurez droit. Il y a des
mesures pour les aînés,
notamment une bonification de
l'exemption de revenus de
travail qui va faire en sorte
que vous pourrez garder votre
supplément de revenus garantis.
Davantage d'argent du supplément
de revenu garanti. Et nous
l'annoncions hier soir, les
producteurs laitiers sous
gestion de l'offre, les, avala
également, le total du succès
pour ce qui est des
compensations sur les accords
commerciaux avec les pertes de
marché et le soutien également
avec la valeur des quotas qu'on
veut garantir s'élève à 3,65
milliards.
- Donc les faits saillants sont
faits. Revenons à l'achat d'une
première maison pour les jeunes,
enfin, l'achat d'une première
maison. C'est une des mesures
phares.
- Exactement. Vous dîtes pour
les jeunes parce que l'objectif
c'est justement de faire en
sorte que les milléniums aient
accès à une propriété dans un
monde ça coûte de plus en plus
cher, s'acheter une maison. Le
RAP, le régime d'accès à la
propriété qui était de 25 000 $
présentement va passer à 35 000
$ que vous pouvez emprunter de
votre réelle pour investir dans
une mise de fonds pour investir
dans une première propriété. Et
une nouveauté, un nouveau
programme annoncé aujourd'hui au
la SCHL va participer pour une
part de 5 % à 10 % votre
hypothèque c'est-à-dire que
votre remboursement hypothécaire
sera abaissé de cette somme. Par
exemple, sur une maison de 400
000 $, la SCHL pourrait mettre
40 000 $ que vous allez
rembourser quand vous allez
vendre votre maison, ce qui va
réduire les paiements
hypothécaires que vous allez
faire. Ça peut être des bonnes
sommes. Plusieurs centaines de
dollars pour les gens qui ont
accès à cela. Donc première
mesure structurante, c'est
celle-là. L'achat d'une première
propriété.
Vous avez un exemple :
je pense que ça va plaire à des
gens justement qui veulent
s'acheter une première
propriété...
- ça va faire une différence
entre l'achat et être incapable
d'acheter pour plusieurs
personnes.
- Absolument. Mais il y a quand
même un plafond. On ne va pas
acheter des maisons à 1 million
à Vancouver avec ça. C'est
important de le dire. Mais on
peut acheter une maison de 400
000 à 500 000 $ avec sa et avoir
un soutien. La deuxième mesure
structurante, c'est le crédit
pour la formation de 250 $ par
année pour les personnes de 25 à
64 ans. Vous pouvez accumuler
comme ça jusqu'à 5000 $. Si vous
gagnez jusqu'à 150 000 $ par
année. Donc dès 2020, c'est de
l'argent qui est là, qui est
disponible, on ne vous l'envoie
pas la maison mais elle est
disponible pour vous si vous
avez besoin de retourner au
collège, à l'université,
poursuivre une formation. Il y a
également la possibilité d'avoir
un soutien de quatre semaines,
55 % de votre revenu moyen pour
de la formation également. Ça
c'est la mesure formation. La
mesure pour les aînés c'est sur
le supplément de revenu garanti,
pour encourager les aînés à
rester au travail, l'exemption
complète ou partielle sur le
revenu d'emploi ou de travail en
ce moment ça va jusqu'à 15 000
$. Parce que souvent vous allez
gagner de l'argent, un petit
travail à temps partiel, ça
vient amputer votre supplément
de revenu garanti. On dit que
maintenant, jusqu'à 15 000,
c'est une exemption complète ou
partielle, il y a toutes sortes
de détails mais ça va vous
permettre de toucher davantage
d'argent pour ce qui est du
supplément de revenu garanti.
L'autre mesure importante
aujourd'hui, c'est pour les
producteurs sous gestion de
l'offre. Il y a 2,15 milliards
disponibles pour compenser les
coûts qui sont associés aux
pertes de revenus associés aux
accords commerciaux négocier
avec le rap et le partenariat
transpacifique. Il y a également
1,5 milliard pour garantir les
quotas.
- Madeleine, on revient une
seconde sur la question du
déficit. Est-ce que c'est un
risque au plan politique? Parce
qu'on dit qu'il va baisser au
cours des trois dernières années
mais il n'y a pas de programme
pour l'éliminer.
- Absolument pas. Il n'y a pas
de date de retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire. On a posé la
question en point de presse à
l'intérieur du huis clos au
ministre Bill Morneau : à quand
le retour de l'équilibre
budgétaire? Il refuse de
répondre à cette question. Alors
on est dans la catégorie des
promesses rompues. Parce que
lors des dernières élections, le
gouvernement avait fait le pari
d'éliminer le déficit, mais il
avait dit qu'on retournerait à
l'équilibre budgétaire en 2019.
Mais on n'a pas de date de
retour à l'équilibre budgétaire.
Gérald le disait, c'est
pleinement assumé. Le
gouvernement fait maintenant le
pari qu'il vaut mieux injecter
de l'oxygène dans les gens, dans
les familles, plutôt que de
penser écrire un budget à
l'encre noire. On pense que
c'est plus payant politiquement,
finalement, d'agir de la sorte,
et que l'économie s'en porte
mieux. On montre, preuve à
l'appui, le taux de chômage qui
a été à son plus bas niveau en
40 ans, les centaines de
milliers d'emplois créés depuis
le début du mandat, mais ça va
devenir une ligne de démarcation
avec les conservateurs, ça c'est
sûr et certain. De toute façon,
même s'il y avait eu un plan de
retour à l'équilibre budgétaire,
même si on avait dit dans 10
ans, dans cinq ans, on aura le
retour à l'équilibre budgétaire,
les conservateurs auraient
attaqué les libéraux en disant :
vous avez rompu votre promesse,
on ne vous croit plus.
- Les libéraux pourront demander
aux conservateurs : qu'est-ce
que vous allez couper de ce
budget?
- Exactement. Et on ne veut pas
montrer qu'on est en position de
faiblesse ou en position
défensive, on montre même une
certaine offensive en disant,
comme vous le dîtes Patrice, on
dit aux conservateurs :
justement, où allez-vous couper?
Ça devient une position
d'attaque d'une certaine façon
de part et d'autre part
- et on a beaucoup souligné, le
ministre a dû le faire, on aura
des extraits d'une entrevue que
Gérald a faite avec le ministre
des finances, on a sans doute
souligné le ratio PIB dette.
- Il continue sur une pente
descendante, c'est le nouvel
ancrage du Parti libéral qui dit
: on est des gens fiscalement
prudents, parce que voyez-vous
ce ratio PIB dette, un peu plus
à comprendre que le déficit,
mais c'est la taille du déficit
par rapport à l'économie au
complet. On est sur une pente
descendante donc l'économie se
porte bien. Évidemment, s'il y a
ralentissement économique, est-
ce qu'on va être en mesure
d'investir davantage? On verra.
On voit aussi qu'on essaie de
maintenir un déficit qui est
sous la barre des 20 milliards
de dollars. C'est psychologique
un seuil que l'on ne veut pas
dépasser.
- Gérald, on a parlé depuis
quelques jours de cette fameuse
assurance médicaments, il y a un
processus pour mettre en place
cette fameuse assurance au
Canada, est-ce qu'il y a des
détails?
- On commence à avoir détails
mais il va falloir être patient
avant de voir le coût des
médicaments baisser au Canada.
Mais en sens inverse avec ce qui
est annoncé aujourd'hui. On
parle d'une agence canadienne
des médicaments. Pour l'instant
on parle d'un bureau de
transition. Il y a de l'argent
qui dans ce budget a été
présenté pour faire la
transition. Les médicaments
coûtent 20 % de plus au Canada
que dans d'autres économies
avancées et ça coûte presque 34
milliards de dollars en
médicaments. L'objectif avec
l'agence canadienne des
médicaments, c'est de négocier
l'achat de médicaments pour le
compte des différents régimes
d'assurance qui existe au Canada
pour pouvoir baisser le coût des
médicaments. On va aussi créer
un formulaire national de
médicaments sur ordonnance. Ça
s'en vient, deux mil 22 août
2023 pour la suite des choses.
Et Madeleine mentionnée qu'il
n'y avait pas de saupoudrage.
Mais on a quand même ciblé
certaines choses en tentant
d'aller peser sur les bons
boutons : voitures électriques,
100 % électriques. Il y a un
incitatif au Québec de 8000 $,
vous pouvez ajouter 5000 $ du
gouvernement fédéral en
incitatif. Pour les voitures
électriques, il y a aussi des
incitatifs pour les entreprises,
pour qu'il vienne déduire
l'achat d'une voiture
électrique. L'Internet haute
vitesse, c'est encore là cinq à
6 milliards pour 42 035 % des
Canadiens soient branchés à la
haute vitesse. Et bien sûr,
soutient aux autochtones,
presque 5 milliards de dollars
supplémentaires sur cinq ans.
- On va parler de la dette dans
une seconde. Parlez-moi de la
frontière. Je crois qu'on a
annoncé de l'argent pour tenter
de calmer ou d'apaiser cette
histoire avec les migrants qui
entrent de façon illégale au
Canada. On met de l'argent aussi
là-dedans. C'est un peu une
réponse au discours des
conservateurs également.
- C'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas
de compensation, la compensation
continue à être négocié pour ce
qui est de la compensation aux
provinces pour les réfugiés.
- On annonce de l'argent pour
sécuriser la frontière?
- Justement, il y a de l'argent
qui est prévu pour la frontière
mais je n'ai pas le montant sur
les yeux en ce moment.
- C'est 1,7 milliard.
- Vous posait la question mais
vous le saviez.
- Voilà, c'est le jeu.
- C'est un des secteurs
où on sent qu'il y a de
l'inquiétude sur tous ces
migrants qui passent à la
frontière de façon entre autres
irrégulières. Alors le
gouvernement veut se montrer
proactif sur ce côté. Il y avait
des négociations avec Québec
pour rembourser les dépenses
supplémentaires engendrées pour
la province de Québec avec tous
les migrants qui avaient
traversé notamment jamais
Roxham, mais là, il n'y a pas
d'argent encore parce que ce
négociations ont toujours cours.
On sait que les négociations de
ce projet de loi gouvernementale
avec Québec et Ottawa, on ne
s'entend pas encore.
- Gérald, la dette.
- Bien c'est important, la
dette, parce que ça vient
appuyer je vous dirai toute la
logique des libéraux de
maintenir le gouvernement dans
des déficit. Malgré les
déficits, la dette baisse, pas
en dollars, mais puisque la
croissance économique est plus
importante que la hausse de
l'endettement on va passer en
2017-2018 à 30,7 % et à 28,6 %
selon les projections pour 2023-
2024 donc le gouvernement pense
que tant et aussi longtemps
qu'on investit dans l'économie
et qu'on voit la tête baissée,
on peut faire des déficits. En
2015 on disait que l'équilibre
budgétaire c'était le budget
d'aujourd'hui. Aujourd'hui on
oublie ça complètement, on
mettait les déficits et on a
toujours pas de cible de retour
à l'équilibre budgétaire.
- Très bien. On aura les
réactions qui seront
recueillies. Mais j'ai hâte de
voir, d'abord, la réaction des
provinces, la réaction des
producteurs laitiers, est-ce que
ce sera jugé suffisant? La
réaction du milieu des affaires?
Vous avez pu parler à des gens
dans le huis clos. Premières
impressions?
- Les entreprises, je vous
dirai, on s'attendait peut-être
un petit peu plus du côté des
entreprises. On est un peu déçu.
Mais en même temps, dans
l'énoncé économique du 21
novembre, il y en avait sur la
déduction de l'amortissement
accéléré donc il y avait déjà
des mesures pour les entreprises
de ce côté. Les producteurs
laitiers vont probablement dire
que ça prend du temps annoncé.
Oui, on met les sommes, mais on
aurait souhaité aujourd'hui que
les sommes soient versées
directement, ciblé directement
et qu'on est davantage
d'informations sur le soutien
qui sera accordé. Je vous
rappelle qu'on a le partenariat
transpacifique, l'accord avec
l'Europe, l'accord avec les
États-Unis et le Mexique qui
s'en vient, c'est presque 10 %
d'ouverture du marché des
produits laitiers. Les
producteurs affirment qu'ils ont
besoin de soutien. Mais là on a
des chiffres. On a un peu plus
de 2 milliards de dollars pour
compenser et on vient ajouter
1,5 milliard pour s'assurer de
la valeur des quotas sous
gestion de l'offre dans le
futur.
- Ça va être le cas avec
plusieurs aspects de ce budget,
on n'a pas les détails. Pour les
producteurs laitiers, c'est
vrai. On va peut-être être
rassuré en partie devant claire
et nette, écrit. Mais en même
temps, comment ça va
s'articuler, ce programme? Il y
a eu une grande déception après
les compensation offerte pour
l'accord avec l'Europe parce
qu'on avait dit : il faut
investir. Ce n'est pas
nécessairement recevoir de
l'argent dans ses poches pour
compenser les fromages fins qui
rentrent de l'Europe sur le
marché canadien. Et il n'y a pas
encore d'argent de prévu pour
l'ALENA 2,0 qui évidemment n'est
pas encore ratifiée par les
trois pays. Pour ce qui est de
l'assurance médicaments, on
parlait des plates-bandes
néodémocrate, c'était la
prochaine frontière de
l'assurance-maladie selon le
NPD, ça fait 20 ans qu'il le
promette. Alors on va avoir
l'impression qu'on est en train
de jouer dans leur territoire.
Mais en même temps, on n'a pas
les détails. On est en train
d'élaborer tranquillement
quelque chose. Donc peut-être
que c'est prometteur mais il y a
encore beaucoup de chemin à
faire avant de comprendre
comment tout cela va
s'articuler.
- C'est l'esquissés d'autres
détails arriveront dans la
plate-forme électorale à
l'automne, manifestement.
- Et quelle sera la marge de
manoeuvre pour qu'on en promette
plus? Ça reste à voir. Parce
qu'on est un déficit d'environ
20 milliards, si on arrondit. On
ne pourra pas nécessairement
annoncer beaucoup plus de
nouvelles mesures coûteuses sans
peut-être agacer l'électorat,
qui est plus sensible à ces
questions budgétaires.
- Mais en même temps, ce n'est
pas grand-chose, les déficits, à
15 ou 20 milliards, c'est en bas
de 1 % du produit intérieur
brut. Aux États-Unis on est à
quatre ou 5 % du PIB. En Europe
on a du mal à atteindre la cible
qui n'est pas le déficit zéro
mais d'atteindre un déficit qui
représente 3 % du PIB. Mais les
libéraux envoient surtout le
message qu'ils assument
pleinement qu'on ne va pas au
déficit zéro parce que s'il le
voulait, ce serait possible,
nous sommes en croissance
économique année après année, il
serait possible d'aller là. Ça
c'est une chose. L'autre chose,
ce sont les éléments plus
fondamentaux qui sont annoncés
aujourd'hui et qui répondent à
des besoins de l'économie et du
marché du travail. Quand on
parle de formation à long terme,
le monde du travail change vite.
Il y a des emplois qui vont
disparaître. On est dans
l'automatisation des fonctions.
Il faut améliorer notre
productivité, c'est le genre de
chose qui peut aider.
- Sur la formation, Gérald,
donner moins en davantage,
concrètement, ça fera une
différence que ces crédits, que
ces programmes pour la
formation?
- Oui ça va faire une
différence, parce que c'est en
trois volets en quelque sorte.
Le crédit pour la formation
faite en sorte que vous
travaillez, vous entrez sur le
marché du travail, vous arrivez
à 40 ans et on vous dit que vous
avez besoin d'informations
supplémentaires, que votre
compétence est un peu désuète
par rapport à la suite des
choses. Qu'est-ce que vous
faites? Compte tenu que
l'économie s'accélère,
s'automatiser davantage, il
faudra faire de la formation.
Donc vous aurez un compte,
jusqu'à 250 $ par année, qui est
cumulatif jusqu'à 5000 $ et vous
pourrez payer la moitié de votre
formation collégiale,
professionnel ou universitaire.
Ça va obliger aussi les
établissements d'enseignement
être beaucoup plus branché sur
les besoins du marché du travail
à faire des offres intéressantes
pour les gens qui ont besoin
d'une formation supplémentaire.
On travaille avec l'assurance
emploi. Également les quatre
semaines disponibles à 55 % du
revenu moyen du travailleur pour
faire en sorte que le
travailleur puisse prendre congé
et puisse aller travailler. Et
les PME sont compensées
puisqu'elles pourront avoir une
baisse de cotisation à
l'assurance emploi. Et il y a
des congés, également, qui
seront disponibles pour les
travailleurs qui doivent suivre
des formations. Donc c'est un
nouveau programme. Des détails
s'ajouteront. Ça s'inspire de ce
qu'on a vu à Singapour.
Singapour, c'est 500 $ par
année, compte formation. Ici on
se contente plutôt de 250 $.
Essaie de mettre de l'argent de
côté pour vous encourager à vous
former pour avoir une économie
plus productive et plus
spécialisée, poursuivre les
mouvements économiques.
- Je vais poser la question à
Michel C. Et à René visionnant
dans une seconde, mes
madeleines, est-ce que selon
vous, Messieurs, j'arrive à vous
dans une seconde, selon vous,
est-ce que la teneur de ce
budget Morneau, quatrième, va
faire en sorte qu'on va changer
le climat à Ottawa?
- C'est une très bonne question
parce que généralement, un
budget préélectoral comme ça, ça
s'analyse dans un contexte
justement de est-ce que ça va
faire l'côté en vue des
prochaines élections. Mais là,
c'est plutôt : est-ce que ça va
faire la cote d'ici demain, est-
ce que ça va changer le temps à
Ottawa, est-ce que ça va
permettre de tourner la page en
toute cette affaire SNC-Lavalin?
Moi je ne suis pas certain,
parce que les grandes lignes de
ce budget, on les connaissait
déjà. On avait déjà entendu
parler de voitures électriques,
de formation de la main-d'oeuvr,
d'accès à la propriété. C'est
dans ce budget. Est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose là-dedans, un gros
wow je ne l'avais pas vu venir?
Non, ce sont des mesures qui
sont en lien avec ce que le
gouvernement libéral a fait
jusqu'ici. Il y a des mots-clés
bien sûrs. Mais il va falloir
plus que ça pour changer le
temps à Ottawa. Mais c'est quand
même un chapitre important
dans le cycle financière du
gouvernement. Ils ont leurs
prévisions. Ils ont leurs
programmes principaux, qu'il
projette. Alors les
conservateurs, les néodémocrate,
les blocs est vont pouvoir
maintenant mieux présenter les
leurs et mieux répliquer à ce
que le gouvernement propose.
- Est-ce que le ministre a pu
commencer à parler on est encore
dans ce délai? C'est pour ça. On
va vous le montrer.
Parce que les libéraux ont été
presque plus rapides à la fin
dans cette joute parlementaire.
Le ministre a déposé le budget
de telle façon qu'on a pu parler
de son contenu même si les
conservateurs avaient jeté des
votes et voulaient faire de
l'obstruction. Ça n'a pas
fonctionné. À tout de suite
madeleines. Michel et René
Vézina, tour de table,
impression générale de ce budget
Morneau?
- C'est pas mal ce qu'on
attendait sorte que si vous me
permettez, il y a quand même
quelques vues de l'esprit. Il
faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont. De permettre à
des jeunes de retirer jusqu'à 35
000 $ de leur REER pour le
régime d'accès à la propriété,
il faut l'avoir, les 35 000 $
dans le REER. On disait cette
semaine que dans l'ensemble de
la population, il y a une
personne sur huit qui a un REER
qui doit puiser dedans pour
joindre les deux bouts
seulement. Mais l'idée de la
participation de la SCHL, on
arrive avec une aide au
financement qu'on remboursera la
vente de la propriété.
- On demande au gendre,
désormais, on pourra leur
demander pour certains types de
maisons, de financer non pas 100
% de la propriété mais 90 % de
la propriété et donc, ce sont
des charges moins lourdes.
- Au départ, d'entrée de jeu.
Mais on commence à avoir un
léger flottement à l'échelle du
pays. Mais je trouve que de dire
: aller chercher le 35 000 $
dans votre REER je ne connais
pas beaucoup de jeunes de 25 ans
qui ont cette somme.
Autre mesure, la somme de 250 $
pour la requalification des
travailleurs, quand vous êtes
jeunes, pas de problème, mais
pour les travailleurs plus âgés,
qui sont bouleversées par la
restructuration du marché du
travail, ça ne leur fera pas
beaucoup d'argent, ce ne sera
pas un incitatif, quant à moi.
Je pense qu'il aurait fallu
aller cibler des groupes et leur
donner carrément de quoi
s'absenter du milieu du travail
pendant un temps pour aller
chercher l'information
supplémentaire dont ils ont
besoin. Le ratio de la dette
par rapport au produit intérieur
brut, elle descend, c'est une
tendance continue. Et cette
année on pense que l'économie
canadienne va continuer à
croître, je ferai attention.
Dire qu'il faudra attendre
jusqu'en 2030, on aura peut-être
des colonies sur Mars.
Et Internet haute vitesse,
il faudrait attendre jusqu'en
2030. Mais c'est sur Internet ou
cour qu'il faut agir.
- Michel, sur le fameux vote que
les conservateurs ont forcé,
c'était beaucoup moins utile
d'un point de vue stratégique
parce qu'on a pu parler du
contenu du budget. Ils n'ont pas
réussi à retarder.
- Ceux qui n'ont pas vu, c'est
que Monsieur Morneau est allé
déposer en chambre les documents
et donc ce n'est pas un outrage
à la chambre d'en parler s'ils
sont déposés. Donc on a levé le
huis clos à quatre heures
- et on a pu en parler. Mais
c'est très bien. Parce qu'on
aurait pu veiller tard. Michel,
premières impressions?
- C'est un budget politique très
ciblé. Ce n'est pas un budget
rempli de bonbons, mais les
budget rempli de bonbons, si ça
marche, Philippe Couillard
serait premier ministre
aujourd'hui au Québec. Alors je
pense que c'est très ciblé, et
madeleines le disaient, pour
aller chercher la clientèle du
NPD. C'est tout à fait exact.
Toute la question de l'assurance
médicaments. Il y en a un Québec
mais pas dans les autres
provinces ou c'est un réel
problème. Donc de l'aide pour
les gens qui ont des maladies
rares et des médicaments qui
coûtent très cher. D'autres
parents va créer une agence
canadienne du médicament pour
qu'on puisse acheter en gros et
faire baisser les prix. C'est
dans le programme de Québec
Solidaire, ça vous donne une
idée?
Alors donc, il y a vraiment des
Pour le reste,
René avait raison. Un
travailleur de 53 ans qui veut
se recycler d'un autre chose,
ça ne l'a pas beaucoup. Les
jeunes, ça va les aider.
Mais ça donne l'impression que
le gouvernement d'une part a le
contrôle des finances. Il n'a
peut-être pas le contrôle du
déficit. Ça, c'est important.
Les milieux financiers
aujourd'hui vont dire que ce
n'est pas si important que ça si
on regarde le ratio.
- La règle du déficit zéro
et remise en question. 1 % du
PIB, c'est viable.
- Si l'Allemagne est capable de
faire des déficits, nous aussi
on serait capable.
- On peut y arriver si on a une
trajectoire. Ça pourrait être
acceptable. Mais j'ai hâte de
voir demain l'évolution du
dollar canadien. Ce sera un
indicateur. Est-ce que l'on
pense que c'est crédible.
Aujourd'hui il grimpait de façon
substantielle. Cela s'est
effrité en cours de séance.
C'est un indicateur à savoir si
l'on pense que tout cela se
tient. On verra cela dès demain
matin. J'ai hâte de voir le
flottement que ça peut faire.
Il faut avoir la marge de
manoeuvre pour agir en cas de
coup dur. Le gouvernement se
peinture dans le coin.
- Si on se résume, il y a des
choses qui étaient attendues.
Cela crée moins de surprises. Eu
l'accès à la propriété, les
médicaments, les producteurs de
lait...
- c'est très ciblé
politiquement. Pas juste au
Québec d'ailleurs. Il y en a
beaucoup en Ontario de
l'industrie laitière. Ce sont
des comtés qui peuvent basculer
au conservateur. Alors aider les
producteurs de lait est-ce que
ça veut dire dans une communauté
rurale quand les fermes vont
bien, c'est extrêmement
important.
- Le chèque s'en vient.
- M. Trudeau va pouvoir être
bien accueilli dans les fermes
durant la campagne électorale.
- Des mesures qui peuvent être
intéressantes mais attendues.
Est-ce qu'il y a un facteur wow
pour sortir Justin Trudeau de la
crise qui n'en finit plus avec
SNC-Lavalin.
- Pas à court terme, pas demain
matin. Mais un moment donné,
pour alimenter une crise, pour
qu'elle dure. Ça va
s'éteindre tranquillement.
M. Trudeau devrait être plus
habile pour ne pas faire
d'erreur trop souvent. C'est un
scandale qui va s'estomper
tranquillement.
- René Vézina, vous surveillez
la valeur du dollar.
- C'est le baromètre.
On imaginerait qu'on est peut-
être sur une glace mince.
Effectivement, il n'y a pas de
facteurs éblouissants mais il
n'y a pas de méchant surprises.
Je rajoute un élément. 600
millions de dollars pour
l'industrie des médias qui
traversent une période très
difficile. Dont un crédit de 15
% pour un abonnement à des
publications numériques.
J'imagine que ce ne sera pas sur
les grands médias
internationaux. On verra ce que
ça donne. Il y aura probablement
des mesures intéressantes que
l'on va découvrir au fur et à
mesure. C'est intéressant
Patrice. Un budget est secret,
confidentielle et maintenant, la
plupart du temps, on a
l'essentiel de ce qui sera
annoncé.
- C'est rare un budget où on a
une immense surprise. Il y avait
beaucoup de mesure à l'époque
qui touchait les taxes sur le
tabac, les cigarettes. Plusieurs
mesures fiscales. Là, c'est
beaucoup plus calme sur ce
front.
- Il n'y a pas beaucoup de
problèmes de contrebande.
Les taxes sont nos péchés sont
tellement élevées que l'on va
repartir un problème de
contrebande si on n'y touche. On
n'a pas besoin d'aller là.
- Revoyons les faits saillants.
Un tableau général d'abord.
- 20 milliards de dollars de
déficit. Dans les faits
saillants, bonification de
l'aide à l'achat d'une première
propriété. C'est un nouveau
programme pour aider les
nouveaux acheteurs. Pas
nécessairement riche. C'est à
peu près entre 400 et 500 000.
Dans certains marchés, c'est
déjà quand même assez élevé.
Donc bonification de l'aide à
l'achat d'une première propriété
avec un régime qui passe de 25
000 à 35 000 $. Un crédit à la
formation pour les travailleurs
de 25 à 64 ans qui ont besoin de
se former au cours de leur
carrière. C'est un crédit à la
formation. Pour les aînés, on
vient bonifier l'exemption de
revenus de travail et d'emploi
si vous travaillez, si vous êtes
sur le marché du travail. Ça va
jusqu'à 15 000 $. Exemption
totale ou partielle. Votre
supplément de revenu garanti ne
sera pas altéré. Ça demeure
essentiellement le même avec
cette bonification. Pour les
producteurs de lait et les
autres producteurs sous la
gestion de l'offre un appui de
3,65 milliards de dollars.
Également pour garantir la
valeur des quotas de gestion de
l'offre dans le futur.
- Vous avez rencontré le
ministre des finances dans le
huis clos. Vous pouvez présenter
un premier extrait.
- L'enjeu principal et le
déficit. Le budget devait être
le budget de l'équilibre
budgétaire. C'est une promesse
qui n'est pas tenue par les
libéraux.
- Je sais que d'être responsable
au niveau fiscal est très
important. C'est pour ça que je
suis très heureux de dire que
nous pouvons avoir les
investissements mais en même
temps pour diminuer notre dette,
diminuer notre déficit chaque
année. Notre bilan est meilleur
aujourd'hui que les années
auparavant. C'est une approche
responsable mais avec les
investissements pour les
Canadiens et les Québécois.
- Mais vous aviez promis
l'équilibre budgétaire.
- Il y a toujours des
changements dans l'économie.
L'économie va bien.
- 3 %.
Que fait-on s'il y a une
récession.
- C'est important d'avoir des
investissements.
- On préfère investir. C'est ce
qu'il vous répond. On va mettre
au défi les conservateurs en
disant : montrez-moi où vous
allez couper.
- Montrez-nous à quel endroit il
faut faire des compressions. On
est à 20 milliards de déficits.
Qu'est-ce que l'on doit
supprimer pour revenir au
déficit zéro. Le Canada a une
note de crédit de AAA.
On emprunte pour presque rien
sur les marchés présentement.
L'OCDE et le FMI le rappelle :
c'est sans doute le meilleur
moment pour emprunter et
investir. C'est le message du
ministre Morneau. L'équilibre
budgétaire, le déficit zéro, que
l'on s'est donné au fil du
temps, est-ce qu'il doit être
atteint sur un budget de plus de
330 milliards : jusqu'à quel
point est important d'y arriver?
Le ministre dit qu'il préfère
investir et stimuler l'économie.
Si on se met à couper, ça va
ralentir l'économie. Mais je me
demande, s'il y a une récession,
si les taux d'intérêt se mettent
à monter, est-ce qu'on va aller
à 50 milliards de dollars de
déficit? La croissance
économique a été forte dans les
dernières années. On laisse à
plus tard le résultat, le
travail pour revenir à
l'équilibre.
- Madeleine, parlez-moi de
l'assurance médicaments. Ce sera
une partie importante de la
plate-forme libérale lors de la
prochaine campagne électorale.
Création d'une agence
canadienne. Qu'est-ce que ça
change pour les gens qui
achètent des médicaments demain
matin.
- Ça va changer mais pas demain
matin. Le programme n'est pas
encore en place. Mais
éventuellement, les médicaments
vont coûter moins cher. On est
l'un des pays où on paie le plus
cher. Le gouvernement a peu
d'informations sur ce que
d'autres pays paient pour leurs
médicaments. On veut changer le
rapport de force face aux
producteurs de médicaments. Est-
ce que l'agence va accepter des
médicaments qui entrent au pays
à la condition que l'on s'entend
sur un prix. Actuellement, ce
sont deux organismes : un
organisme qui accepte les
médicaments au pays et l'autre
qui s'occupe du prix des
médicaments. On va réussir à
faire des économies de 3
milliards de dollars pour les
médicaments. Ce n'est pas
nécessairement les Québécois qui
vont davantage en bénéficier
parce que l'assurance
médicaments n'est pas égale
partout. On a une courtepointe
au pays. Les Québécois sont
généralement bien assurés. Si
les prix des médicaments
baissent, au Québec, on pourrait
avoir plus d'argent dans nos
poches. Le 20 % qui restent,
s'il est moins cher, évidemment
que ce sera plus d'argent dans
les poches des Québécois. La
marge sera peut-être moins
importante au Québec
qu'ailleurs.
- Je ne vous entends plus
Patrice.
- Pendant qu'elle se
rebranche, ceux qui croyaient
qu'on aurait une assurance
publique pour tous au Canada,
est-ce que c'est cela?
- On jette les bases de cette
idée mais on n'y est pas encore.
Dans le dernier budget, le
gouvernement avait annoncé la
création d'un groupe de travails
pour étudier cette question. Il
y a un rapport préliminaire qui
a été rendu public il y a
environ un mois. La première
recommandation était pour
s'attaquer au prix des
médicaments. Avant même d'avoir
une assurance médicaments, on
veut s'attaquer au prix.
Le rapport subséquent d'ici
l'été nous mènera peut-être à
une option. En ce moment, on
parlait d'une courtepointe. Le
système privé, public, des
médicaments couverts dans
certaines provinces et qui ne le
sont pas dans d'autres. Comment
faire un tout cohérent? Est-ce
que l'on comble les écarts où on
essaie de repartir à zéro et
essayer d'avoir un système
compréhensif avec un système
public. Ce sont des décisions
qui devront être prises.
- On s'en va vers le
remplacement, l'accompagnement
des personnes qui n'ont pas de
couverture de médicaments pour
couvrir leurs médicaments. Plein
d'entreprises ont des régimes
privés mais le régime public
n'est pas là pour beaucoup de
gens. Un système universel
viendrait remplacer l'ensemble.
- Ça vient couper l'herbe sous
le pied des néo démocrate. Ils
vont dire qu'ils ont une idée en
place. Alors que les libéraux
ont un plan d'avoir peut-être
quelque chose. On sent que ce
sera la défense des néo
démocrate. Ils ont peut-être une
idée plus complète de ce qu'ils
veulent faire.
- Ou les libéraux vont avoir une
idée plus complète d'ici la fin
de l'été. C'est fort possible.
J'explique aux gens ce qui se
passe en chambre. On est en
attente du dépôt du document. Il
n'a pas pu parler encore. Les
conservateurs, on va écouter.
- Le personnel libéral n'aurait
pas dû faire circuler cette
motion alors que nous étions en
train d'en prendre connaissance
dans la salle de comité. Parfois
on se plaint sur la fuite de
rapports. Toutefois, le secret
des séances à huis clos ne
s'applique pas aux motions. Je
cite : la chambre par le passé
concernant la publication d'un
rapport de comité à huis clos il
s'agit d'une atteinte aux
privilèges.
- On est furieux du côté
conservateur parce que le
ministre Morneau a pu déposer
son budget même s'il n'en a pas
fait encore la lecture. Avec
moi, Serge Coulombe, professeur
titulaire à l'université
d'Ottawa. Vous allez bien? Vous
en avez vu des budgets. Je vous
demande une impression générale.
Comment avez-vous reçu ce
quatrième budget Morneau.
- Du point de vue de la question
de l'équilibre budgétaire, qui
fait la manchette présentement,
il persiste et signe. Ils ont
laissé tomber la recherche de
l'équilibre budgétaire durant le
premier mandat. Ils se sont
rendus compte que c'était une
bonne chose. C'est un choix
politique. Du point de vue
économique, ça se défend très
bien étant donné la marge de
manoeuvre que le gouvernement
canadien a. Il a un faible
niveau d'endettement.
- Il y a des chapelles en
économie. Il y a des points de
vue. Des opinions. À l'heure
actuelle, si vous regardez
l'ensemble des économistes
importants au pays,
il ne faut pas faire une
obsession du déficit zéro. Où en
sommes-nous dans le point de
vue?
- Il y a eu un changement au
cours des trois ou quatre
dernières années. Il y a presque
consensus mondialement.
L'équilibre budgétaire n'est pas
nécessairement, ça peut être un
bon objectif, mais ce n'est pas
le seul objectif possible
surtout pour un pays comme le
Canada qui est peu endetté. Ceci
découle de la faiblesse des taux
d'intérêt. Le gouvernement
canadien peut emprunter à des
coûts très faibles. Il peut
investir. C'est une autre
solution qui se défend. Ça ne
veut pas dire que c'est meilleur
que l'équilibre budgétaire mais
du point de vue de la science
économique, rien ne contredit le
fait d'avoir un déficit qui
somme toute est très faible. On
est très loin du seuil de danger
au niveau international qui est
à 3 %. Ces quatre à cinq fois
plus élevées.
- On est très peu endetté au
Canada. 705 milliards je crois.
C'est la dette. Un déficit de 9
milliards cette année. Cela est
peu endetté?
- Ces 30 % du PIB. Notez qu'un
critère de dangerosité, c'est 70
% du PIB. C'était ce que l'on
avait en 1973. Le ratio continu
à descendre tranquillement. Il
est faible. Adopter une cible de
faire descendre le ratio plutôt
que d'atteindre l'équilibre
budgétaire c'est un objectif qui
se défend.
- C'est très clair. Par
ailleurs, dans les mesures,
qu'est-ce que vous retenez comme
important.
- Ce sont des mesures qui
frappent beaucoup certaines
personnes qui sont de nature à
voter pour le NPD ou pour les
libéraux. C'est vraiment un
budget de type néo démocrate. Je
m'explique. La bonification de
l'exemption du revenu garanti.
Pour les gens qui gagnent entre
10 000 et 20 1000 $ par année et
qui sont pauvres, 4000 $ de plus
dans leur poche par année. Ce
serait intéressant que le
gouvernement du Québec aille
dans cette voie également. De
façon à encourager les retraités
de ne pas perdre cette somme
lorsqu'il décide de travailler.
Les entreprises devraient
accueillir chaleureusement cette
mesure. Ils sont très intéressés
à embaucher des gens qui ont de
l'expérience.
- Cela est important. Ça fait
une vraie différence.
- Ça fait une différence dans le
bien-être d'un sous-groupe de la
population qui avait été un peu
oubliée. Le montant n'avait pas
été renouvelé depuis 2008. Donc
chaque année, ce groupe payait
plus de plus en plus d'impôts.
Tu packs une autre mesure?
- L'allocation canadienne pour
la formation. C'est un nouveau
programme qui va donner 250 $
par année dans un fonds quand on
travaille à temps plein. On peut
accumuler jusqu'à 5000 $
maximum. On peut utiliser
l'argent pour la formation
professionnelle.
- Qui recevra le 250 $?
- Les personnes qui font de la
formation professionnelle. Ces
données aux gens. Plusieurs
personnes aujourd'hui en milieu
de carrière ont parfois l'idée
d'aller suivre 1, Cours d'un ou
deux mois pour changer de
vocation. Avec ce programme, on
facilite l'ajustement à l'offre
de main-d'oeuvre et en même
temps, on a facilité le lien
avec le régime d'assurance
emploi. Finalement, c'est un
programme qui risque d'avoir
beaucoup de succès du point de
vue de la formation de la main-
d'oeuvre. Il ne faut pas oublier
aussi l'accès à la propriété. On
a copié ce qui a été fait à la
Ville de Montréal. C'est un
programme de partage de risque.
Pour les premiers acheteurs de
propriété, ils vont payer 10 %
moins de paiement hypothécaire
par mois si c'est une maison
neuve et 5 % si c'est une autre
maison. La SCHL va participer au
gain ou à la perte de capital.
C'est un régime tout à fait
intéressant. Le rap risque
d'avoir une incidence importante
sur les personnes. On sentait
qu'il y avait des mesures qui
touchaient beaucoup les gens.
C'est électoraliste. Ça veut
dire si vous voulez vraiment
profiter de ces mesures,
remettez-nous au pouvoir.
- Bien sûr.
- Ce n'est pas du saupoudrage
comme dans le passé. Ce sont
vraiment des choix politiques.
- C'est du clientélisme. Les
premiers acheteurs, ceux qui
veulent faire de la formation,
les personnes âgées. Très bien.
Serge Coulombe, est-ce que vous
vous attendiez par ailleurs à
plus ou à moins?
- J'ai été surpris par l'ampleur
des mesures. Un peu déçu que
certaines soient mises en oeuvre
uniquement après la prochaine
élection. Que voulez-vous, c'est
la politique. Mais du point de
vue économique, c'est un budget
satisfaisant. Mais sur le plan
politique, il est très
intéressant.
- Serge Coulombe, professeure à
l'université d'Ottawa, merci
beaucoup. Alors il y a des
réactions à ce budget. Estelle,
vous êtes en compagnie de
Monique Moreau.
- Ce budget comprend des mesures
pour faciliter la formation des
travailleurs. Cela ne vous
satisfait pas totalement.
- On aurait aimé des mesures
structurelles pour le rôle de
l'entrepreneur. Un employé de
construction pourrait partir
pour 1, Cours culinaire pendant
quatre semaines? Quand est-ce
qu'ils vont prendre cette
formation? Il manque de détails.
Dans les prochaines semaines,
avec les élections, mais pour
nous, on aura plus de détails et
fixer le rôle de l'entrepreneur.
- Le gouvernement
annonce un déficit. Tu packs les
- Les petits entrepreneurs
on regarde ça avec beaucoup
d'attention et un peu
d'inquiétude.
- Merci beaucoup Mme Moreau de
la fédération canadienne des
entreprises indépendantes.
- Merci Estelle. On se retrouve
avec d'autres réactions. Je vous
rappelle que si l'on n'a pas
entendu le chef de l'opposition
et les autres politiciens qui
viennent habituellement devant
les micros, c'est que le
ministre n'a pas commencé à
livrer son discours du budget.
Les conservateurs font de
l'obstruction. Nous on a pu en
parler dès 16 heures avec vous
parce que le ministre a pu quand
même rapidement déposer le
discours du budget en chambre.
- Quand on est arrivé ici, le
ministre était déjà là et il
nous attendait. Il avait déjà
déposé le budget. Il a voulu
court-circuiter les
conservateurs. On a pu expliquer
les mesures en long et en large.
- Les gens de la première
chaîne, il y aura les émissions
régulières un peu plus tard.
Nous, on continue l'émission
spéciale parce que le ministre
n'a pas encore parlé. Il y aura
des réactions de l'opposition.
Revenons aux faits saillants si
vous voulez. D'abord, les
revenus et les dépenses. Il y a
un déficit.
Ce déficit fait jaser.
- Du côté des libéraux, on
maintient que ce n'est pas
important de revenir à
l'équilibre budgétaire. M.
Harper trouvait extrêmement
important d'être à l'équilibre
budgétaire. Il visait
l'équilibre budgétaire. Ici, on
avait promis d'être à
l'équilibre budgétaire mais en
étant difficile. Il n'y a pas de
cible de retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire. On fait le difficile
parce qu'on investit dans
l'économie canadienne et dans
les Canadiens. Dans les faits
saillants, bonification de
l'aide à l'achat d'une première
propriété. On veut aider les
jeunes ménages à avoir accès à
la propriété. Dans un pays où
les prix ont augmenté. À
Montréal également les prix
augmentent. On bonifie le régime
d'accès à la propriété. On va
pouvoir avoir un prêt de la
SCHL. L'économie change. Il faut
améliorer la productivité. Il
faut changer d'emploi à
l'intérieur de son entreprise,
on crée un crédit à la formation
un peu comme à Singapour. Pour
les travailleurs de 25 à 64 ans.
Un crédit de 250 $ par année.
Vous pouvez l'utiliser pour
suivre une formation.
Pour les aînés, bonification de
l'exemption de revenus de
travail. Pour faire en sorte que
votre supplément de revenu
garanti ne soit pas abaissé
parce que vous travaillez, parce
que vous allez travailler
davantage. C'est une mesure
quand même importante qui va
toucher beaucoup de Canadiens
qui veulent travailler.
Pour les producteurs sous
Un soutien qui comprend une
compensation pour les pertes de
marché avec l'ouverture
notamment dans le lait et qui
prévoit 1,5 milliards pour
s'assurer de la valeur des
quotas de production qui sont
sous gestion de l'offre.
- On a beaucoup parlé en attente
à savoir s'il irait de l'argent
supplémentaire pour le transport
en commun. La ville de Québec,
Montréal, Vancouver, les grandes
villes canadiennes ont des
besoins énormes en transport en
commun.
- Rien de nouveau dans ce budget
sur le plan des infrastructures
et du développement. Le tramway
de Québec par exemple, le REM
s'était déjà annoncée, mais le
tramway et l'à la ligne bleue,
des projets qui sont en
négociation nous a dit le
ministre. Il s'est un peu
désengagé en disant que ça
dépendait des municipalités, des
provinces. Ce que le
gouvernement annonce
aujourd'hui, c'est une somme
dans les infrastructures de 2,2
milliards qui est ponctuel et
envoyée aux municipalités pour
les infrastructures. Certains
trouvent que cela ressemble à un
cadeau électoral, ça vient d'un
coup. Mais on dit que c'est
normal pour le gouvernement
fédéral compte tenu de ses
engagements RV avec une somme
supplémentaire pour soutenir les
municipalités.
- Restez là. Je vais entendre
comme vous le réaction de la
fédération des municipalités.
- La présidente de la fédération
canadienne des municipalités est
très contente du dépôt du budget
en raison de plusieurs mesures,
d'abord l'injection de 2,2
milliards de dollars
spécifiquement destinés aux
municipalités. De quelle manière
ça vous sera utile?
- Ça va passer par le fonds qui
provient de la taxe sur
l'essence. Certains font qu'on
utilise déjà depuis plusieurs
années qu'il est facile, qui est
prévisible et qui sert pour les
infrastructures. Tous les
citoyens peuvent en bénéficier.
Cette année, on va parler
beaucoup des routes, de l'eau
potable. C'est efficace. On va
pouvoir faire rapidement des
projets.
- De quelle manière allez-vous
distribuer l'argent?
- Je connais pas le niveau de
détail, mais ça va passer comme
actuellement comme la taxe sur
l'essence. Les municipalités
savent déjà combien ils ont. On
entrait dans des détails que
j'ai pas encore.
- On parle d'une somme de
milliards de dollars destinés à
un fonds vert, une autre bonne
nouvelle pour les municipalités
en matière d'infrastructures.
- C'est une belle marque de
confiance. Le fonds est géré par
la fédération canadienne depuis
20 ans déjà. On vient bonifier
en ajoutant des volets, pour le
logement social, pour la
résilience face au changement
climatique, la gestion des
infrastructures. Cela répond
directement à nos demandes.
- Une autre demande était de
connecter l'ensemble des
Canadiens à Internet. Est-ce que
c'est assez vite 2030 selon
vous?
- On estimait que ça prendrait
10 ans.
- Voici le ministre Bill Morneau
qui peut enfin donner les
premiers mots de ce discours sur
le budget. Si vous le voulez
bien, on va l'écouter.
(Chahut)
Monsieur le président, j'ai
rencontré des jeunes, il voulait
s'amuser. Ils avaient des
questions il se souciait
beaucoup de monde qui s'entoure.
Je suis heureux de vous faire
part du troisième budget de
notre gouvernement.
(Chahut)
(propos inaudibles)
(chahut)
- vous aurez compris mesdames et
messieurs que c'est pas votre
télé qui fait défaut, ce sont
les conservateurs en chambres
qui font du brouhaha pour éviter
que le ministre soit audible,
que sa voix vous atteigne. C'est
réussi sur ce plan. Les mesures
d'obstruction, Gérald,
Madeleine, Michel C, René,
n'avait pas fonctionné mais ça,
ça a bien fonctionné. Il me
semble qu'on voyait ça davantage
à l'époque, mais qu'on était
passé à autre chose.
- On entendait "point of order"
ça empêche d'entendre le
discours du ministre. Il me
semble qu'on était passé à autre
chose. Mais on a au moins pu
avoir le budget. Dans le temps,
les histoires de la chambre
fermée pendant 20 jours, des
affaires comme ça, ça ne
pourrait plus arriver. Je suis
pas sûr que les conservateurs
cèdent beaucoup en faisant ça.
- C'est ce que j'allais
demander. Trop, c'est comme pas
assez.
- Il y a un risque politique
évidemment incomplètement
empêcher un gouvernement de
fonctionner. C'est un dépôt de
budget, c'est important pour les
Canadiens, ils vont vouloir
savoir s'ils vont avoir plus
d'argent demain matin. Il y a un
risque. Visiblement, les
conservateurs pensent qu'il y a
encore du kilométrage à faire
avec toute l'affaire SNC
Lavalin. On ne veut surtout pas
la laisser mourir cette
histoire. C'est en partie pour
cela qu'on essaie de faire de
l'obstruction pour permettre
éventuellement à Jodi Wilson-
Raybould de parler davantage, on
est dans cette dynamique. On
veut à tout prix donner de
l'oxygène à cette histoire pour
qu'elle dure le plus longtemps
possible. On a l'impression
qu'elle en ce moment au parti
d'opposition.
=- Si nous sommes diffusés sur
la première chaîne, je salue les
téléspectateurs de Radio-Canada.
Il y a le dépôt d'un budget,
c'est le moment important en
démocratie, des changements qui
touchent à peu près tous les
citoyens. Dans ce budget,
Gérald, vous en parlez, les gens
qui veulent de la formation, les
jeunes qui veulent acheter une
première propriété, les aînés,
il y a des choses qu'il faut
expliquer, il y a une limite à
bloquer le chemin aux libéraux.
- Il y a des éléments
fondamentaux dans un budget,
vous avez la feuille de route,
le premier budget qu'on va
présenter à Québec jeudi, des
éléments fondamentaux pour les
quatre prochaines années, là il
y a des aliments fondamentaux
pour faire le bilan des quatre
dernières années, ce qui s'en
vient. En même temps, c'est
aussi, on la fait remarquer au
ministre aujourd'hui, une base,
une plateforme pour les
élections. Donc oui,
conservateurs aujourd'hui,
l'opposition officielle font de
l'obstruction, mais en même
temps, le jeu politique veut
également que le parti au
pouvoir prenne la place, face à
des annonces qui ne sont pas
encore chiffrées et qui demeura
détailler. D'ailleurs, il y en a
plusieurs de ces mesures qui ont
été annoncées. On pense à
l'assurance médicaments, à
l'achat d'une première
propriété, le soutien pour les
aînés également, les véhicules
électriques, etc. il y a
beaucoup de mesures qui sont
intéressantes et bonnes pour
l'économie, mais dont les
mesures restent à être
déployées, détaillé, on se garde
ça pour des annonces dans la
campagne électorale.
- Le sou texte est de dire,
l'économiste nous disait tout à
l'heure : voter pour nous sinon
les mesures vont tomber dans un
puits sans fond. Il y a des
mesures qui vont changer la
dynamique. Les personnes âgées,
ça peut être jusqu'à 4000 $ de
plus pour les personnes âgées
qui reviennent sur le marché du
travail. C'est important.
- Il faut comprendre qu'il y a
un phénomène qui est
pancanadien, c'est qu'on
commence à gratter les fonds de
tiroir pour trouver l'effectif
nécessaire pour faire rouler
l'économie. Il y a un problème
particulier au Québec avec le
vieillissement de la population.
Mais c'est un peu partout au
Canada. Il faut s'assurer
d'avoir un maximum, utiliser à
leur plein potentiel les gens
qui pourraient vouloir
travailler et qui par moments
n'y voient pas un avantage parce
qu'il pourrait perdre des
revenus, qui n'ont pas les
qualifications ou les
compétences. Il y a un début de
plan. Je dirais que par rapport
au fait qu'il faut voter pour
avoir droit à ses promesses, il
n'y en a pas beaucoup de
promesses de ce genre, elles
sont minimes par rapport à ce
qu'on a déjà vu par le passé. Un
élément intéressant, je vois les
commentaires des économistes
notamment Monsieur Porter de la
BMO qui dit : peut-être que le
Parry du gouvernement pourrait
tenir parce que les revenus
fiscaux du dernier mois de
l'année en cours sont supérieurs
aux prévisions. On va chercher
plus d'argent. Donc il y a peut-
être un facteur de mitigation.
On est sur une belle tendance.
Ça pourrait être intéressant.
- Cet argent supplémentaire, les
revenus supplémentaires dont
bénéficie le gouvernement, le
gouvernement a décidé de les
dépenser. Le gouvernement aurait
pu réduire la taille du déficit
par rapport à la dernière mise à
jour de l'automne où on
prévoyait justement un déficit
frôlant les 20 milliards de
dollars. On a eu environ 5
milliards de dollars de revenus
supplémentaires, on a permis
d'avoir 5 milliards de mesures
supplémentaires, sans toucher à
la taille du déficit : les
revenus, on les injecte dans
l'économie. On pense qu'il vaut
mieux donner de l'oxygène aux
gens plutôt que d'équilibrer le
budget. On pense que c'est plus
payant politiquement ou plus
efficace aussi pour stimuler la
croissance économique à moyen
terme, entre autres avec la
question de la formation de la
main-d'oeuvre pour permettre aux
travailleurs de s'adapter à
l'économie de demain. Il y a
beaucoup de questions d'anxiété.
Vous allez entendre le ministre
parler d'anxiété. L'économie se
porte bien, il y a un taux
d'emploi qui est impressionnant,
pas de chômage, plus bas niveau
en 40 ans. Par contre, il y a
des Canadiens qui s'inquiètent
encore pour payer leurs
factures, acheter une maison,
être parti intégrante de
l'économie de demain. C'est ce
que le gouvernement veut faire,
essayer de toucher à ces points
d'anxiété en annonçant certains
programmes qui sont quand même
assez larges mais qui touchent
directement certaines personnes.
- J'ai été frappé de voir que
l'association des municipalités
du Canada était assez
satisfaite. Il y a une
injonction d'argent de plus pour
les infrastructures. Donc on
sent que cela calme un peu, les
attentes étaient énormes là-
dessus.
- N'oublions pas une chose, il y
a une élection qui s'en vient.
La ligne bleue du métro à
Montréal, le tramway à Québec,
ce sont des belles annonces
élection aussi, il ne faut pas
l'oublier. Le gouvernement a
décidé de dépenser l'argent
qu'il entrait en surplus parce
que les revenus sont au-delà des
prévisions. C'est aussi de la
dépense plus directement
électorale. Il faut pas
s'attendre à ce que le
gouvernement se prive de
l'affaire pendant une campagne
électorale.
- Le gouvernement s'est donné un
nouvel outil d'investissement
avec la banque des
infrastructures, un immense
programme de 187 milliards de
dollars. Il y a du retard dans
le déploiement de cela. En 2015,
on disait qu'il fallait investir
dans les infrastructures pour
stimuler l'économie. Depuis
quatre ans, il y a eu des
annonces, mais beaucoup plus
lentement que prévu. Ça prend
beaucoup plus de temps que prévu
de développer des projets
d'infrastructures. On sait qu'il
y a... à la ligne bleue, on en
parle depuis 30 ans. De dire
d'un concept qu'on va régler la
ligne bleue, qu'on va stimuler
l'économie avec ça, ça prend du
temps. On va probablement
annoncer quelque chose d'ici les
élections là-dessus.
- Monsieur Morneau vous a donné
une entrevue et vous lui avez
posé la question des producteurs
laitiers ils ont eu un certain
nombre de réponses aujourd'hui.
On écoute un extrait.
- On va garder l'approche du
gouvernement précédent, 2,4
milliards de dollars pour le
secteur, mais nous savons que
nous devons avoir...
c'est pour ça que nous avons
expliqué que l'argent est là, on
va avoir des discussions pour
s'assurer qu'on a une approche
qui va être bonne...
- à quand l'annonce, la
précision des annonces?
- Les discussions sont en train
d'être fait en ce moment.
- En 2019?
- Je suis pas dans les
discussions. Je suis certain
qu'on va continuer avec notre
approche. Nous voulons le faire
aussitôt que possible.
- J'ai essayé.
- Avant le 20 octobre?
- C'est pas garanti. J'ai essayé
de savoir c'étais quand. Les
producteurs laitiers, les
producteurs sous gestion de
l'offre ont besoin de cet
argent. Au moins, il y a des
sommes. 2,100 50 milliards
disponibles pour compenser les
accords commerciaux et 1,5
milliards en programme de
garantie de valeur des quotas.
- On va aller voir la réaction
de la fédération des producteurs
de lait en compagnie d'Estelle.
- Monsieur Lampron qui accueille
plutôt favorablement ses
investissements du gouvernement.
Plus de 3 milliards, c'est une
bonne nouvelle.
- Oui, on accueille
favorablement l'annonce dans le
budget fédéral aujourd'hui. Le
gouvernement reconnaît les
concessions que les producteurs
laitiers ont faites dans les
derniers accords.
- De quelle manière allez-vous
dépenser ou du moins espérez-
vous que cet argent soit
réparti?
- On demande que ce soit réparti
par tous les producteurs
équitablement à travers le
Canada selon leurs parts de
marché, on veut que tout le
monde est la même par des pertes
qu'ils ont subies à travers le
Canada.
- On n'a pas encore le détail de
la façon dont cet argent sera
réparti à l'échelle du pays.
C'est une source d'inquiétude?
- Je pense qu'on a des groupes
de travails qui ont travaillé,
la ministre Bibeau a été nommé
dernièrement, on va la
rencontrer la semaine prochaine.
Les annonces sont faites
aujourd'hui. On est content.
- Il n'y a pas d'argent pour le
nouvel Alena négocier avec les
États-Unis et le Mexique. À ce
compte, vous gardez vos attentes
assez élevées comme pour la
renégociation des autres accords
avec l'Europe et le partenariat
transpacifique?
- L'entente n'est pas ratifiée
encore. On sait pas ce qui va
arriver avec ce qui se passe à
l'international. La porte est
ouverte à reconnaître les
dommages qui ont été faits.
- Un soupir de soulagement pour
les producteurs laitiers du
Canada. Voilà Patrice, un autre
son de cloche positif après le
dépôt du budget.
- Merci Estelle. Imaginez une
campagne électorale si on avait
pas fait la paix avec les
producteurs laitiers, ça aurait
été long.
- D'autre part, en s'assurant
que peut-être pas l'échec
complet mais un peu d'argent et
rentrer dans chacune des fermes
laitières au Canada, dans des
régions rurales, des régions
importants pour la réélection du
parti libéral, on s'assure que
les ministres vont être bien
reçus quand ils vont passer là.
C'est important dans une
élection. D'autre part,
effectivement, les producteurs
laitiers ont bu la tasse dans
les accords de libre-échange ont
été signés. On voulait peut-être
pas, c'était l'une des demandes.
On leur avait promis, c'était
une demande de Monsieur Legault,
en mettant cet argent sur la
table, cela empêche un certain
nombre de choses qui auraient pu
être désagréables pour le
gouvernement.
- Marie-Claude Bibeau a été
nommé à l'agriculture aussi.
C'est la première femme à
accéder à ce poste. On voulait
probablement avoir une porte-
parole qui est incapable de
parler aux Québécois entre
autres. On savait que c'était un
secteur où on pouvait avoir une
vulnérabilité en vue des
prochaines élections si tous les
détails ne sont pas sur la
table, on a maintenant des
chiffres, une façon de rassurer
les producteurs et un porte-
parole pour expliquer le tout.
- Les réactions sont positives.
Je sais pas si vous avez pu
entendre l'union des
municipalités, les gens étaient
plutôt satisfaits de ce qui s'en
vient. On a voulu apaiser.
- Si vous permettez, on parle de
2 milliards pour les
municipalités. C'est pour
l'ensemble du Canada. Il y en a
beaucoup de municipalités. Je
comprends qu'il y a une
ouverture de ce côté, mais je
fais une parenthèse, il faudra
voir avec le budget du Québec
dans deux jours si l'attribution
d'un point de TVQ se
concrétisera. Évidemment, ça
aiderait beaucoup. Pour le
budget fédéral, c'est une bonne
idée d'en attribuer par rapport
à tous les milliards qu'on
espère voir arriver, à la ligne
bleue, très, tout ce que vous
voulez, 2 milliards c'est bien,
ça va payer peut-être...
- Ça peut faire une différence.
On cherchait une enveloppe pour
le tramway. Peut-être que le 2
milliards ici et là-bas apaiser
des chicanes qui auraient pu
faire beaucoup de bruit.
- Espérons-le.
- Réaction du chef du NPD.
(en anglais)
- si nous analysons la vie des
Canadiens, les gens qui ont des
enfants, ils vont continuer de
dépenser jusqu'à 25 000 $ par
année pour des soins, pour les
garderies, parce qu'il n'y a pas
de soutien pour ces gens. C'est
le petit montant qui leur est
donné ne fait rien pour 25 000
$ de coûts. Quand quelqu'un est
pluvieux et veut acheter une
maison, gouvernement n'a rien
dans le budget pour construire
des logements abordables, rien
pour aborder les coopératives,
ils offrent aux gens d'utiliser
leur aire pour acheter leur
maison. Combien de milléniaux
sont en mesure... en même
derrière?
des Reer.
Cela montre à quel point il est
déconnecté de la réalité
canadienne. Beaucoup de
milléniaux n'ont pas d'emploi
vraiment solide : ce sont des
contractuels, ils ont des
emplois précaires. Ce budget
devait parler de la nouvelle
formation. Il n'y a rien pour
les milléniaux en poste
précaire. Quand on est un peu
plus âgé, on veut avoir des
médicaments dans sa vie, il n'y
a rien pour mettre en place une
couverture de médicaments
universels pour tous les
Canadiens. On dirait que ce
gouvernement a cédé à la
pression des grandes
pharmaceutiques et n'a pas
apporté les changements qui
auraient réduit le coût des
médicaments. Finalement, quand
quelqu'un veut prendre sa
retraite, le gouvernement ne
fait rien pour fermer les
lacunes dans les lois actuelles
qui ont permis aux compagnies de
vol et des fonds de pension. La
situation avec Sears par exemple
ou 700 millions de dollars ont
été volés. Cela n'a pas été
corrigé dans ce budget. Tout au
long de la vie d'un Canadien ou
d'une canadienne, la vie n'est
pas améliorée, beaucoup de gens
vont continuer à avoir du mal.
14 milliards pour les plus
riches dans l'énoncé économique
de l'automne. Il n'y a rien pour
fermer ces échappatoires pour
les options d'action des
dirigeants des grandes
entreprises. Alors il n'y a plus
rien pour les gens normaux quand
le gouvernement a déjà tout
distribué aux riches.
Il n'y a rien pour les
garderies, c'est toujours le
coût qui est presque de 25 000
$ pour quelqu'un pour avoir ces
services de garderie. Si on
parle de la première fois que
quelqu'un veut acheter une
maison, on peut utiliser les
REER, combien de gens ont assez
d'argent dans les
les gens qui ont des emplois
précaires, les gens qui prennent
leur retraite, aucune mesure
dans ce budget pour arrêter le
vol des pensions, quelque chose
qui s'est passé avec les
employés de Sears. On voit que
le gouvernement continu de
donner des cadeaux aux grandes
entreprises, aux plus riches,
mais des miettes pour tout le
monde.
- Voilà, Jagmeet Singh qui n'est
pas satisfait. Il rappelle que
les mesures, assurance
médicaments, aide pour les
milléniaux pour l'achat d'une
propriété, ce sont des mesures
que les NPD veut et va proposer
aux Canadiens lors de la
prochaine campagne électorale.
C'est comme s'il voyait un peu
le tapis lui glisser sous les
pieds.
- C'est très clair. Il reste une
chose que les NPD veut, la
construction de logements
sociaux. Il va pouvoir faire
campagne là-dessus. Meeting, sa
signature politique jusqu'à
maintenant, c'est vraiment le
logement. Le fait qu'on va aider
les milléniaux à acheter des
maisons, c'est bien, mais en
même temps, il y a pas grands
milléniaux qui ont 35 000 $ dans
un REER. C'est une mesure
intéressante mais pas tant que
ça. Il y a parti SCHL qui est
plus intéressante, mais il y a
un problème d'argent comptant
pour acheter la maison. Il va
falloir voir comment Jagmeet
Singh se lance, se donne un
programme sur le logement
social, parce que c'est vraiment
là où il y a une ouverture.
- Un élément dont on n'a pas
parlé qui est significatif,
c'est une somme imposante. On
attribue 3,25 milliards pour les
services destinés aux
autochtones, pour les Premières
Nations pour des questions de
qualité de l'eau. On sait à quel
point c'est déplorable dans bien
des endroits au Canada. Pour les
soins aux enfants, d'autres
mesures de soutien. C'est une
belle somme. Je comprends que ça
n'affecte pas pour tout le
monde, mais il y a vraiment...
je sais que ce n'est pas
clientéliste. Je pense qu'il y a
vraiment une mesure qu'il faut
saluer, quelque part, des gens
vivent dans le quart- monde au
Canada. Sinon ce sont des
mesures qui visent des groupes
précis. Il y a beaucoup de si
là-dedans. L'Internet 2030, je
trouve que c'est un peu lent. À
bien des endroits à travers le
Canada, il y a de la
dévitalisation. Pour participer
à l'économie du XXIe siècle,
c'est urgent.
- Vous restez avec nous. Une
nouvelle de dernière heure. Une
alerte Amber qui a été lancé en
Ontario. La police de la ville
de Markham près de Toronto est à
la recherche d'une fillette de
cinq ans.
Elle aurait été enlevée par son
père à son école.
Le père n'a pas la garde de
l'enfant. Ils auraient quitté
les lieux en taxi. La jeune
fille porte un chandail rose et
des leggins. Il y a une licorne
sur son sac à dos. Le père est
âgé de 25 ans. Vous voyez le
père. Si vous avez des
informations, vous communiquez
avec la police régionale dont le
numéro apparaît à l'écran.
Excusez-moi, on va remettre la
photo après. On écoute Andrew
Scheer.
- 41 milliards de dollars de
nouvelles dépenses financées par
des hausses d'impôts s'il est
réélu. C'est le camouflage le
plus cher de l'histoire du
camouflage. Ce sont des déficits
budgétaires pour cacher le
scandale avant l'élection et des
hausses d'impôts après les
élections.
Le scandale de corruption d'SNC
Lavalin a complètement consumé
le gouvernement de Justin
Trudeau depuis des semaines. Le
ministre des finances a présenté
un budget comme si c'était tout
à fait normal. Mais ce n'est pas
normal. La situation est
anormale. On ne peut pas rester
là les bras croisés pendant que
les libéraux font semblant du
contraire. Justin Trudeau a
essayé d'arrêter la poursuite
criminelle d'une compagnie qui
était partisan des libéraux en
intimidant son procureur général
Jodi Wilson-Raybould pour
qu'elle change sa décision.
Quand elle n'était pas d'accord,
il la congédier. Il ne veut pas
lui permettre de dire aux
Canadiens ce qu'elle fait à ce
propos. Un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui, il a fermé la seule
enquête publique sur ce scandale
de corruption. Ils disent que la
dissimulation est plus grave que
le crime. Mais Justin Trudeau a
cru que le contraire était vrai.
Il n'y a rien de pire que cette
situation. Monsieur Trudeau a
perdu deux de ses ministres
seniors par démission. Son
meilleur ami et conseiller
principal a dû remettre sa
démission.
- Aux téléspectateurs de la
première chaîne, nous disons au
revoir. Nous poursuivons la
couverture du budget sur RDI.
Voici le numéro à appeler pour
l'alerte Amber. La fillette
aurait été enlevée par son papa
à Markham en Ontario. Merci
beaucoup de votre attention.
Pour les autres, nous
poursuivons la couverture avec
toutes les réactions.
À la prochaine.